Mario has always smashed blocks now he's
also smashing the box office the Super
Mario Brothers movie had the biggest
opening weekend of 2023 so far and there
are lots of reasons why
the Super Mario Brothers franchise began
way back in the medium's infancy with
the 1981 arcade release Donkey Kong it's
officially blew up in popularity with
the worldwide release of the Nintendo
Entertainment System known in Japan as a
famicom in the mid-80s even then critics
were sure that Super Mario Brothers
would be an international phenomenon
Mario has remained a staple of
Nintendo's carefully curated brand ever
since the series has spawned countless
spin-offs from Mario Kart to Mario Party
some of these side projects rank among
the best-selling video game franchises
of all time apart from the broader Mario
umbrella that is more than 800 million
Mario video game units have been sold
with the series most recent entries
Super Mario 3D World Plus Bowser's fury
on Nintendo switch selling just under 10
million units in 2021. this series has
been Prime material for adaptation into
an animated film for a very long time
its colorful Aesthetics unique world and
lovable casts of characters not only
appeal to kids but to nostalgic adults
who grew up with the franchises early
the entries it's no surprise that the
series video game success has translated
to its box office win
Super Mario Brothers movie is a
Nintendo's first brush that's
translating their most beloved franchise
to film in 1993 the live-action Super
Mario Brothers movie starred Bob Hoskins
and John Leguizamo as Mario and Luigi
respectively similar to the illumination
movie the film follows the two
blue-collar brothers working as plumbers
in Brooklyn before they're centered
through an interdimensional portal to
another world inhabited by a kingdom of
dinosaurs but things get pretty
different from there notably the film
was a critical failure and bombed at the
box office the New York Times said that
the film's final 30 minutes were nearly
unwatchable and criticized as inability
to capture the magic of the original
games Super Mario Brothers was even
hated by the cast with Hoskins naming
the film was one of his biggest regrets
that said lokozama was embraced it in
recent years I knew you had been in the
Super Mario uh Brothers movie with but
with uh
I'm proud of it I'm proud of it the 30
year old film has develop something of a
cult audience though director Rocky
Morton and Annabelle jankel told variety
that midnight screenings held at Quentin
Tarantino's New Beverly Cinema helps
them feel proud of the work they've done
though Morton admitted that it might
have turned out differently if Nintendo
was more involved nevertheless hardcore
Super Mario Bros fans were optimistic
about illuminations chances given that
Nintendo was very careful with its IP
nowadays with many of them excited
enough to see the film in theaters
there are lots of adults who grew up
playing titles such as Super Mario World
and Super Mario 64. although
illuminations more original projects are
the Despicable Me films or sing May
largely appeal to kids there's a whole
generation of grown-ups who are curious
to see their favorite childhood games
get referenced in the Super Mario
Brothers movie critics seem to be
noticing the film's dedication to
appealing to the franchise's longtime
fans they've noted that the movie is
focused on channeling Nostalgia for the
games while also opening up the world's
new audiences this is arguably a
strength that illumination has lacked
with their previous adaptations of Dr
Seuss's storybooks both the Grinch and
The Lorax were criticized for their lack
of faithfulness to the source material
thankfully faithfulness is a name of the
game in the Super Mario Brothers movie
The film's visuals beautifully recapture
the Aesthetics of recent Mario video
game titles it's also quite the Far Cry
from the 1993 film which took quite a
few major creative liberties with the
design of characters including Bowser
and Toad illuminations film remains true
to the characters video game fans have
come to know and love
even though illumination has been
criticized at times they've never failed
to release a film that does well
commercially the studio debuted in 2010
with the original Despicable Me which
introduced audiences to the minions who
are either adorable or annoying
depending on who you ask they've become
the company's mascots and the spin-off
film minions ranks in the top 30 highest
grossing movies of all time most of the
company's success has been attributed to
their low-cost production with
illumination CEO Chris maladandri
listening off their secrets to the New
York Times very few management layers
clear decision making shortening the
length of time you spend developing a
movie it can be done
the Super Mario Brothers movie does its
utmost to appeal to not only fans of the
series more recent titles but long time
followers from the arcade days whether
it's through iconic 80s needle drops
memorable enemies from the franchise or
broader meta references to the series
history Super Mario Brothers movie is a
blast for anyone who grew up playing
Mario games some critics have actually
knocked the movie for emphasizing
references and visual Fidelity to the
games over plot character development
and themes comparing it and favorably to
other game-centric films like Wreck-It
Ralph it's grown-up stuff you wouldn't
understand that said no Super Mario
Brothers game has ever really been
acclaimed for its story aside from maybe
RPG titles such as Paper Mario the
Thousand-Year Door or Mario and Luigi's
Superstar Saga many of those who care
enough to see Mario and his friends
translate it to the screen likely by
mind a paper-thin story so to speak the
appeal of the games has always been
visuals and action and the movie has
those to spare sequences like Mario and
Luigi's early scenes Brooklyn or Mario's
introduction to the marketplace of the
Mushroom Kingdom a chock full of
references and Easter eggs they're not
just nods to Mario's own series of games
but also Nintendo's other properties for
instance one scene in Mario's bedroom
features references to Star Fox f-zero
and Kid Icarus in the span of a few
minutes a movie likewise pokes fun at
some tropes of the Super Mario Brothers
franchise as Mario and toe tried to
sneak into Peter's Castle they're
stopped by two toad guards who smugly
tell them the princesses in another
Castle align players of the original NES
game was surely recognized every viewing
of the Super Mario Brothers movie is
likely to result in spotting a
background Cameo callback or visual
florist that will excite anyone who's
familiar with the Super Mario Brothers
series for gamers who love getting 100
completion in the games they play the
Super Mario Brothers movie begs for
repeat viewings
prior to the release of the trailers all
fans had to judge the Super Mario
Brothers movie by was the film's
official cast announcement which was
revealed during a Nintendo Direct
presentation in September 2021 among the
most controversial of those reveals was
Chris Pratt as a voice of Mario
replacing the character's longtime voice
actor Charles martinet fans were also
divided over the announcements of
Charlie day as Mario's brother Luigi as
well as Seth Rogen as Donkey Kong many
complained about the blanket decision to
cast Hollywood stars rather than
professional voice actors Brad said that
he understood fans concerns but urged go
watch the movie and and and and and and
then we can talk even with some fans
hesitations about the cast it seems it
turns up to the theater to see for
themselves just like Pratt requested
while some critics felt that Pratt and
day still weren't right for the
characters others felt they delivered
with loyalty originality and comedic
chemistry even Kotaku noted the beauty
of Martin a voicing Mario and Luigi's
dad in a moment that somewhat passes the
torch to the two actors while other boys
voice actors have divided audiences Jack
Black has been receiving nothing but
Goodwill for portraying the film's
antagonist and scene stealer Bowser fans
were excited by the announcement that
black was joining the film but they were
even more thrilled when the film's first
trailer showed that he brought his
A-game to play the king of the Cooper
Army but none of the previews truly
captured Black's fantastic performance
the trailers portrayed Bowser as a
terrifying threat to the Mushroom
Kingdom but in the actual film it's
revealed that Bowser is pining for
Princess Peach's hand in marriage making
for some devastatingly funny moments in
one standout scene Bowser sits at a
piano to sing an Ode to Princess Peach
called peaches and it's a brilliant use
of Black's musical Talent peaches began
to climb the iTunes charts only a few
days after the movie's release like even
stars in a music video for The Ballad
fully clad and bowser-inspired garb
illumination has on occasion been
criticized for its storytelling overuse
of needle drops of popular songs and low
brow humor which is never more present
than in a Despicable Me franchise but
the animation studio is always excelled
in its visuals which often come to life
more brilliantly on a movie screen than
they would on smaller screens the Super
Mario Brothers movie in this regard is
no exception if anything this is a
quality that illumination shares with
Nintendo which is often praised for
creating video games with colorful
vibrant visuals and gameplay but
lackluster stories and narrative themes
frankly the film over delivers when it
comes to its action sequences these
moments are as equally fluid in the
animation as they are overwhelming in a
visual sense take for instance a film's
rainbow road Scene It offers an
action-packed Mad Max Fury Road style
battle between the kangami and Bowser's
forces while playing off tropes and
references from the Mario Kart franchise
Anya Taylor Joy who voices Peach even
drew a comparison between this film and
her upcoming portrayola fioriosa and the
Fury Road prequel bizarre that the two
characters in my filmography that have
the most in common are Princess Peach
and furiosa
early reviews of the Super Mario Bros
movie weren't especially kind about its
cinematic qualities while some rightly
appreciated the film was a love letter
for Nintendo's biggest franchise others
were critical of the plot soundtrack and
humor it was hovering around a 50 critic
rating on Rotten Tomatoes though that
has increased a bit since some critics
even label the Super Mario Brothers
movie as one of illumination's worst
offerings that certainly came as quite
the surprise for hardcore Super Mario
Brothers fans who started worrying that
illumination would wash out the
franchise's most appealing qualities but
lots of moviegoers also seem to ignore
the early criticism ultimately fans had
to be gratified that illumination did a
good job Faithfully adapting their
beloved franchise especially compared to
the 1993 live-action film well it may
not be enough that woo folks were
unfamiliar with the games distrust of
those early reviews convinced skeptical
Nintendo fans to check it out for
themselves video game inspired movies
have had a rocky pass making Nintendo
hesitant to license their intellectual
property to Studios eager to adapt the
company's best-selling games long time
Nintendo game designer Shigeru Miyamoto
who created Mario told variety we were
fearful of all the failure of past iup
adaptations thankfully the tide has
turned lately thanks to more faithful
adaptations of many video games one of
those successes has been the live-action
Sonic the Hedgehog films starring Ben
Schwartz as the voice of the titular
Blue Blur early trailers concerned
hardcore fans of the series due to
Sonic's Design This resulted in the last
minute delay so that Paramount Pictures
could redesign Sonic's look to more
closely resemble its appearance on the
games once the film debuted audience
response to the movie and its 2022
sequel was extremely positive even more
recently HBO had a bona fide hit on its
hands with his adaptation of Naughty
Dogs The Last of Us which worried fans
who were devoted to the original games
actors nevertheless Pedro Pascal and
Bella Ramsey proved themselves to
audiences securing the show a second
season renewal only two weeks into
airing by then fans likely felt better
about the Super Mario Brothers movie
living up to expectations
given the box office failure of the 1993
Super Mario Brothers film Nintendo was
much more Hands-On in terms of making
sure illuminations animated film would
represent the company's brand and be
consistent with the Mario of the games
as a result Shigeru Miyamoto served as
co-producer of the film alongside
melodandre who welcomed the input of one
of the most influential figures in video
game history Miyamoto told Rolling Stone
we started to want to focus on the idea
of wanting people to enjoy Nintendo and
love Nintendo as Nintendo not
specifically as any certain game that
approach to more holistic style of
branding resulted in a film
collaboration with illumination as well
as the addition of the Super Nintendo
World theme park at Universal Studios it
was important for Miyamoto as a Herald
of Nintendo's original Spirit to capture
that Spirits outside the world of video
games Nintendo fans may have been
worried that like the 1993 film
illuminations take on Super Mario
Brothers was substantially diverged from
The Source material but Nintendo was
careful to make sure the film didn't to
race Mario's backstory or
characterization of course this Super
Mario Brothers movie wouldn't be as
adored by fans unless it featured some
of the franchise's most iconic music
tracks composer Brian Tyler Helms a film
score borrowing Melodies and songs from
Cody condo's original music throughout
the franchise's history this is mostly
present in the film's many action
sequences which use familiar themes that
will make any Super Mario Bros fan
squeal with excitement Tyler described
the process of adding condos original
music to the film's soundtrack telling
variety I wanted to have built-in
Nostalgia where it immediately feels
like Mario this even contributes to some
Easter eggs from the film such as
Luigi's ringtone being the iconic
GameCube jingle or Bowser and comic
duetting on piano to play the world one
two music from the original Super Mario
Brothers all that said some fans found
reasons to criticize the soundtrack
along with oddly Place pop songs drawing
some of the film's key moments fans
lamented the lack of credit to composer
Grant kirkope who wrote the infamous DK
rap that is featured in Donkey Kong's
introduction scene
one thing Nintendo found particularly
appealing about making the Super Mario
Brothers movie was a notion that it not
only appeals to longtime fans but also
introduces the world of the game so
those who may not be familiar with it
former Nintendo of America president
Reggie fisa May described the intent of
the illumination partnership to IGN
saying it will be a great introduction
to folks who are not as familiar with
the world of Mario the Super Mario
Brothers movie does a great job of
appealing to younger audiences an aspect
that can also be applied to the Super
Mario video games the games strive off
fun gameplay and lovable characters
rather than complex themes or controls
although the film is certainly not for
everyone many kids will likely walk out
to the theater desperate to play the
latest entry in Nintendo's franchise
even nostalgic adults may find
themselves returning to their favorite
childhood Classics after watching the
illumination movie either way it
wouldn't be surprising if the film's box
office success was a result of either of
these groups going back for seconds
it's a good time to be an animation
studio in Hollywood the past few years
I've seen a boom in original animated
films many film critics credit this
search for the release of Sony's
Spider-Man into the spider-verse which
wow the audience says with its comic
book inspired aesthetic more films have
profited off this mindset including
DreamWork says Puss in Boots The Last
Wish like the Super Mario Brothers movie
it was a Smash Hit at the box office
despite the Shrek film franchise being
dormant since the last person boots film
a decade ago audiences seemed styled for
animation as not only well crafted but
contains more hearts and soul than other
recent franchise films a sentiment was
even Echo during Guillermo del Toro's
acceptance speech at the 2023 Oscars
after winning best animated film for his
stop-motion Masterpiece Pinocchio Del
Toro Champions animation saying
animation is Cinema animation is not a
genre and animation is ready to be taken
to the next step the Super Mario
Brothers movie may not innovate but it
does satisfy audiences hungry for
heartfelt animation
Nintendo is a true video game giant but
there's many intellectual properties and
dedication to giving fans what they want
Nintendo is primed to continue its
commitment in film with the Super Mario
Brothers movie as just the start even
before the film's release both fans and
Industry pundits alike were interested
in the possibility of a Nintendo
Cinematic Universe this feeling was
echoed by the film's cast to express
their hopes for the franchise to have a
future although many film fans are
growing tired of never-ending cinematic
universes and Super Mario Brothers movie
certainly promises more from this world
a post-credits team teases the
introduction of Yoshi while other plot
threads perfectly set up a potential
Donkey Kong Country spin-off even
Charlie day has indicated he'd be down
to a Price's role in the Luigi's Mansion
movie illumination for all of its flaws
knows its way around the franchise and
Nintendo's interest in expanding its
brand only makes this a greater
possibility for Nintendo fans eager to
see their favorite characters on the big
screen seeing the Super Mario Brothers
movie is nothing like Marvel fans seeing
the first Iron Man in 2008
[Music]